and you know what in general I just feel
like the more that I am being more
honest with myself about my feelings and
talking about these things like
sometimes you think the more specific
you get the more like distant it's going
to be then people AR going to understand
but I'm finding like the more specific I
get the more Universal it actually is
and like everybody's everybody's got
something I live with my out you
see it that's where I'm grateful for it
because it's really opened me up I try
not to find like a spiritual meaning in
everything in life cuz I think sometimes
that can like make it overwhelming life
overwhelming sometimes things just
happen but I do think that bigger things
happen in our lives as Catalyst for us
to really grow and I think that maybe
there would have been something else but
without Ms in my life I don't I don't
know where I'd be